allô oui allô oui ah bonjour monsieur
voilà je téléphone parce que je voudrais
parler à monsieur quand huit au oui non
oui c'est à dire que oui en pcv oui si
vous voulez oui oui pardon oui oui ne
quittais d'accord monsieur ne quittez
pas ne quittez pas allô oui vous êtes là
oui oui moi je voudrais parler
akkaoui tôt oui oui on peut lui il paye
le pcv oui je oui bien sûr oui d'accord
win ne quittez pas d'accord mais je suis
ne quittez pas allô oui non c'est moi
qui appelle depuis tous les cp puis ce
que vous faisiez vous avez entendu la
sonnerie c'est mon cas pen oui oui oui
oui vraiment je weeds d'accord monsieur
ne quittez pas d'accord allô allô vous
êtes oui oui à un an je regrette je ne
peux pas parlé plus haut oui pourquoi
voulez vous que je raccroche
pourquoi je vais raccrocher pour
pénélope
mais qu'est-ce qu'on parlait de
l'antiquité et penelope visé à la à la
comédie musicale de dany saval et serge
pressée hier l'équipe lac est là pour
chanter mais je le sais monsieur je
commence aussi reçu mercredi sur place
alors à opel